you chased the director of the film
David Ayer around naked you were naked
is that true and that's one of those
things I just need to confirm I mean it
might happens yeah yeah that means it
happened okay
so what how would it happen that you
would chase the director of the film
naked well he used to pay visits to us
in their trailers like at base camp so
we'd be you know you're shooting a big
movie it takes a little time to get
things done chilling out and you know he
would just kind of rock up uninvited and
he came into my try that one day and I
must have had any clothes on and I'm
just hanging out naked in your trail we
just took a shower because we'd been
under a rain tower or something right
there was like a logical reason for
being it's okay in your own trailer to
be Nate yeah I'm a born naked I like
being naked I you know I get a lot of
things done naked but there are some
things you shouldn't do Nate some things
you shouldn't do now yeah some things
you should try naked yeah that you
wouldn't normally but he comes in and
I'm looking I'm an impulsive dude so I
just kind of I went after him and Jay
Hernandez who plays Diablo in the movie
I could hear behind me saying sick and
boy and it's just you know you've got to
go with one of these things at the
moment happened and I just changed him
naked and you didn't care that you were
naked in front of everyone outside you
were chasing him outside the trailer
just a turd you gotta go with it man
okay you know well one of your cast
mates men should get a photo of it and
we have it here here you are running and
[Applause]
you know it's amazing you look like a
drawing of a guy running on like a
crosswalk sign you know you are perfect
running a lie you're like this naked
it's fantastic I'm just wondering who I
gotta like kill now for dropping that
dude cuz like I do it on that crew ya
know I'm happy to be the fall guy for
you know the shenanigans they want to
embarrass one of us but ah yeah okay
that's interesting
all right shot though the producers
after this yeah yeah yeah we'll let you
know who did it you can pay them back
we'll have them on and they'll humiliate
you again now thanks my that runs around
naked is all shy about it around the law
he went to a Burger King after that
you